welcome to this video in and it's arose
okay so aiming for a Sicilian again
people play this stuff nowadays
interesting entire Sicilian at the
Queenie too probably otherwise okay
Megan okay not otherwise it doesn't make
any sense that's a wrong way to phrase
it but we need to would be a point of
that move on and let's say now we just
transpose something else so I'm trying
this play quick play quick anything
later strategy yeah this is a common
idea here to try to undermine that pawn
so let's go for it
expecting g4 so I can prove it saving
some useful seconds okay now i can still
take only five where are you going all
the way to h5 maybe okay i can keep that
pawn for the moment and john i was
thinking Luke age for might be an
interesting move to irritate the heck
out of him let's do that it was quickly
taken okay right here probably didn't
have a choice but I Scott the night to
have six um maybe if there's some tactic
going on
I do we had position it's really strange
oops I didn't even see that move coming
in the slightest oh my god yeah that
happens when I play quickly other guys
had been on time against me I blunder
stuff I can at least this King is a
little bit insecure Nath's it's really
easy easy to where I was before that was
too superficially dashed out with him
hmm it says some kind of counter play
Bishop age three and I don't know I
bishop f3m in hmm achik f3 back antique
antique here right I'm Bishop takes rook
g4s got Queenie six huh okay when is a
rock up so even if he blunders it's
probably not going to be fatal anyway to
any way to get something going here I
Scott sieve form
I mean you can also take them on on a
file that I attended maintaining rook g3
then just see form and Starwood story
yep unfortunately anyway if I retreat
the bishop we cannot take because of
Queen f2 the only problem is that the
retreat's don't really help me with
anything maybe here I wrote you one
simply wins
hmm these are the cheapest tricks ever
but I'm reduced to that Queenie 20 now
you have no he wants to play offense HS
but if you take screen e5 isn't that
winning for me what is this what is this
so I mean okay I was completely
unnecessary anyway okay we can check on
e3 here it gets in jackets interesting
now King edge to is only move otherwise
i take 83 so let's son we need to
check and it's a draw at least funny
enough just one them have something
better Queen f3 blunders everything is
there something better here queen bee
three maybe sure why not why not i'm
attacking that Bishop them so again I
can check can play all those moves a
time one jacket here and i have d three
possibly i take here and she takes with
the rook I won't ever have something
good then check
check I have cooley for this position
what I mean what's not good it's my time
that's that's not a good a good thing
check check so three pawns and need some
security here for my king to a six check
check check check check check in seconds
check no check I've got a bunch of
chicks here check check no I can take
that check I'm stupid stupid stupid
screwing this up check
check check check white forfeits
hometown I've got exactly one second
left oh I almost must be one of the
luckiest wins in recent memory poor I
mean I just I was root down for
absolutely nothing yeah i like i like it
up to here that's certainly not bad your
black must be okay because white really
has played he five far too far too early
on yeah but i didn't play it right i
mean his rook h4 was a funky move and
it's not even bad i think it's just that
i probably have to do it differently
here the engine wants to take this and
gives me a clear edge interestingly
enough now k there are many weak pawns
many we pawns this is the computers line
okay i took with this here here here
yeah and now I mean I didn't know
absolutely 98 I did not see it I just
didn't pay any attention to that move I
have to go to age 8 and the computer
gives me gives me an edge I don't know I
just thought it was interesting here one
possible idea is that let's say white
place normal move I have this idea for
example like this and i have 9 f 1 it's
interesting this is just crazy check
again I mean the problem was he he was
he wanted to to win fans in a fancy way
Rupe g1 this was I'm sorry
here here went here yeah now absolutely
all moves win but this is not just not
working he was thinking he can take him
and then e7 and everything yeah that's
made just made check check check so I
played that correctly check check check
check again check and this side winning
as it was check it was okay i was had my
doubts maybe I had something something
better but it seems that the engine at
least in that very quick replay m and
doesn't find anything anything
substantial wow that was very lucky
thanks for watching